this meeting takes place every november
in the settlement of slave descendants
it's a moment to relive stories of
brazil's dark and silenced past
many say slavery is over but we still
feel its consequences and undergo a lot
of pressure to leave the lands which are
rightfully ours
sixty-two families live in this quilombo
mangara chiba 130 kilometers from the
city of rio de janeiro it's one of the
five thousand communities scattered
around brazil
built by former slaves
many of them had run away hiding from
their masters the 1988 constitution gave
their descendants the right to claim
their lands and keep their traditions
like small-scale farming
that's easier said than done the manga
chiba kilombo has been at the center of
a battle with an investment company that
wants to build a resort on its lands
will not negotiate our history nor our
rights we're only here today because we
resisted otherwise we'd have been kicked
out
until recently people who live here were
not allowed to enter or leave the
settlement freely they were stopped at
the gate built by the company and forced
to hand over 50 percent of their produce
that changed when they were put under
state protection
we stepped in because their lives were
being threatened and are still at risk
the eco-invest company doesn't allow the
electrical company to install
electricity in the colombo
et de valdo philippi blames the lack of
electricity for the death of his oldest
daughter had leukemia and needed
medicine which had to be stored in a
refrigerator but we couldn't have one
because we had no light
earlier this year the mangara chiba
kilomo scored an important victory the
brazilian state finally recognized its
lands which include landmarks of the
settlement's difficult past
these are the ruins of one of many
plantations in rio de janeiro that
thrived until brazil became the last
american nation to abolish slavery in
1888
josonna dominguez takes her son to the
places where their african ancestors
were forced to work slavery may have
ended 133 years ago and blacks in brazil
now outnumber whites but the struggle
for equal rights she tells him is far
from over monica yanaki of al-jazeera
mangara chiba